welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this
episode were breaking down one of the
greatest Marvel movies ever made that is
spider-man into the spider this the film
not only won the Oscar for Best Animated
Feature it also showed that Sony knew
what they were doing with spider-man
after their amazing spider-man films
flopped pretty hard I still love you
Andrew and even you electro now
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down all of the insane details
and Easter eggs in the movie that really
make it one of the best comic book films
of all time this list is in every single
detail in the film but we've tried to
focus on things that haven't been
mentioned in most of the other
breakdowns on the movie obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
film yet then I highly recommend that
you check out now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day and please drop a thumbs
up if you enjoy the content without the
way I just want to give a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of into the spider verse okay
so the movie starts off with a glitchy
Columbia logo that hints at the
multiverse existing does this through
numerous versions of the statue and
throughout the movie there are several
hints that even miles his world takes
place in a different one than ours miles
has a poster of chance the rapper in his
room and the figure has a four on his
cap in real life the emcee actually
wears it three on it and this is also a
clue to the Multiversity of the film
Multiversity is a real word because
Grant Morrison made it up we can also
see on Jeffersons uniform that the badge
says PD and why instead of NYPD and a
news report comes from NNC instead of
CNN you can also spot a movie poster
fall from dusk til Sean which was
supposed to be a sequel to Shaun of the
Dead featuring vampires the film called
hold your horses starring Seth Rogen is
also displayed in Times Square so very
minor differences to our dimension the
introductory story by Peter that we get
shows Uncle Ben and in that we can see
that Peter is actually blond teasing
that this isn't a version that we've
seen before and amongst the title
sequence we can see the spider that
eventually bites miles and it has the
number 42 written on it we get a quick
cut of a lottery ball which also
as 42 on it and this was actually
malsu's winning number that allowed him
to get into Brooklyn visions Academy
during the film miles falls off a
building and hits a sign which then
drops the numbers four and two and when
riding on the bus with Peter later in
the film we can also see that the
maximum occupancy is 42 the number 42
also appears at the subway station just
after Peter's death is announced it's
clearly laced throughout the movie and
according to vitamin v on reddit this is
to symbolize the character being the
first african-american version of
spider-man 42 was Jackie Robinson's
number and he was the first black
professional baseball player so yeah
lots of things going on and let me know
in the comments below if you know as
2:42 that we didn't we see that the
spider-man has lived through many
moments similar to what we saw in the
McGuire movies including the train
pulling the switch on kissing Mary Jane
upside down he punched punched a car as
well and also did the best dance moves
ever in a movie ever I'm looking at you
dirty dancing there's also a nod to the
Holland universe in which he holds two
buses from falling over the Brooklyn
Bridge which Apes the MCU webhead
pulling the ferry back together Peters
name badge is also nice and crisp almost
seeming new and this completely
juxtaposes Peter B Parker's budge later
in the movie which is crumpled and messy
symbolizing his style compared to the
first one that we meet spider-man swings
through the city and at one point seven
birds fly by him as he says there's only
one spider-man these seven birds
actually represent the seven versions of
the character that appear in the movie
and it shows that Peter was wrong
cut to Miles his room and there's what
looks like a Superman poster above his
easel hinting that the hero might
actually have had an influence in him
there's also an award ribbon that we see
that looks like Deadpool symbol and it's
nice that they managed to drop these
comic book references into the movie
without them feeling too forced before
you start typing I know Superman is part
of DC in our Marvel anyway miles as dad
takes him to school and says you don't
want to end up like your uncle Aaron
even though these two are estranged we
can see on Aaron's locked phone screen
that he still has a photo of the two
together later we see that Jefferson
also has one of the pair showing that
the two still care about each other
even if they don't talk you can also see
Gwen crossing the row behind Jefferson
and
this is the first time that we actually
see the character we see the book great
expectations mentioned in class during
the school montage miles is later
assigned it after purposely trying to
fail his test this motif carries
throughout the film with miles trying to
live up to the great expectations that
have been set for him his graffiti tag
is also expectations and if with great
power comes great responsibility for
Peter then with great power comes great
expectations for miles at a try not a
force Taiwan anyway we see a lesson in
which dr. Olivia Octavius talks about
the multiverse we don't learn her full
name straightaway as miles stands in
front of the projector but through the
film we do discover her identity the
character actually even wears octagonal
glasses with eight sides which very much
ties into her name
cut to Aaron's and we also see several
clues that he is the Prowler including a
picture that hangs above his sofa that
looks like it actually has the name
written in graffiti over it
Aaron watches community namely the scene
in which Donald Glover where's
spider-man pajamas and Glover actually
plays Aaron in the MCU so this is like a
weird inception of Easter eggs with
Aaron watching the multiverse version of
himself in spider-man's clothes whilst
he's also the version of himself yeah my
head almost just exploded Aaron tells
miles about the hey line and when he
does this on kingpin later in the movie
we can see the text appear behind him
Myles is then bitten and he becomes
gifted with spider powers after
embarrassing himself with Gwen he tries
to learn what to do next
he turns to spider-man comics which give
him a heads up on how to handle his new
abilities I always kind of wondered why
spider-man gave away his identity in
this and then continued to wear a mask
but I guess I'm as stupid as I look
because if you zoom in on the cover you
can see that he says his name is Billy
Barker to hide his true identity Billy
Parker ya know no one's gonna figure it
out myles calls aaron but it goes to
voicemail and we hear that he's out of
town with hindsight we know that he was
actually working for the kingpin and
when miles goes to the subway station we
do see what looks like aaron from behind
hinting that he was just lying we also
see that Myles as a contact called B
Bendis which is a nod to Brian Michael
Bendis who was the creator
character miles thing comes across
spider-man and the Green Goblin duking
it out we can actually see that miles is
spider-sense
initially it's green and purple before
changes to blue and red Aaron's colors
are actually green and purple but the
fact that miles changes shows that he's
no longer going to be led potentially to
a life of crime by his uncle and he will
instead follow in the footsteps of Peter
Peter climbs the switch using a special
set of moves and he manages to get up
top by holding onto the cylinders of the
supercollider later in the film Myles
uses the same technique to get to the
switch and Gwen says to Peter B I didn't
teach him that and I know you definitely
didn't so we do know that this is where
he got it from after being put into the
collider an explosion happens and if you
slow it down you can actually see five
lights burst out which represent the
five traveling spider persons Peter dies
you're gonna cry and Myles gets chased
down by his uncle absolutely loved this
scene and the score is just incredible
with the colors also being amazing we
also see a hint of green and purple with
the Prowler which ties back to his
colors Myles gets out and there's a post
Malone cameo in which he says I think
it's a Banksy Malone song sunflower is
the one that miles can be heard singing
throughout the movie we then see Stanley
who tells Miles that the SU always fits
eventually perhaps suggesting that Miles
will eventually grow into the role but
there's gonna be a great expectation did
you see what I did there
Myles meets Peter at the graveyard and
he electrocutes him the electrocution
travels through his nervous system
instead of his skeleton as is typical in
films this is more scientifically
accurate to what happens during an
electric shock and it's nice that they
took the time to animate all this even
though it only lasts for about a split
second we see in Peters flashback the
tombstone also hit him with a bus and
this is something else you need to watch
in slow motion this spider-man is
actually older than one that we meet at
the start of the movie which is wise
hairs going gray and he started to put
on a bit of weight they raced through
the city and this scene is kind of
similar to Peter attaching himself to
the Train in spider-man 2 also you get a
blink and you'll miss it Stan Lee cameo
when he steps over the pears
lie on the ground miles interrogate
spitter and we can actually see from his
black eye that he heals throughout the
scene also shout-outs king of pirates on
reddit for spotting that the restaurant
they go to has a rating of C for its
hygiene score Peter tells miles and it
closed six years ago in his dimension
and it's likely that the same things
gonna happen to this restaurant the pair
reached the alchemax and we get a bit
where Peter planted out we actually see
a comic book accurate version of Doc Ock
in front of this universe's female one
and this makes Peter re-examine his
personal biases we also see one of Doc's
tentacles on a desk before she sprouts
the arms and this is a little clue as to
who the villain really is I also tried
pausing her desktop to see if there were
any cooler Easter eggs on there but
unfortunately it was all just stuff like
dinner party and student results there
was one file called Ock notes and secret
plans but other than that and a fantasy
league warned not too many
Doc Ock introduces herself as dr. Olivia
Octavius and she says that a friends
call a live later in the movie Aunt May
comes face-to-face with her and also
calls her live and it makes me wonder
maybe these two used to have dinner
parties together anyway they make it out
with a computer after getting chased by
Ock
now shoutouts to Cardinal crew on
YouTube for noticing that as they throw
a bagel off someone's head instead of
the text being an onomatopoeia sound
effect
it just says bagel the crew also pointed
out that the animation for miles
actually symbolizes how out of synch he
is with Peter ability wise miles
initially has half of the frames cut out
with swinging animation so he looks less
smooth by the end of the film now he has
all of the frames in his moves so it
certainly shows that he's more
accomplished and that he's lived up to
the great expectations Gwen shows up and
she actually lands on point because this
version of the character was an
accomplished ballerina we learn in her
story that she saved her father captain
Stacy who still stands as one of the big
debts in spider-man comics she's also
seen kicking the lizard while saying she
couldn't save her best friend this is of
course Peter and we can actually see on
the character's skin and there are
scales showing he took on the Monica in
her universe we also see a doc ock
tentacle but this one is metal probably
more in line with the version that were
more familiar with or maybe I just need
to re-examine
my personal biases they meet Mei and
then go into the spider cave there's a
ton of suits that have all been picked
apart and breakdowns but in the middle
there's actually a mannequin without one
on as we know the Peter of this
dimension didn't come home the three
characters spider senses or trigger upon
meeting the other three versions of
spider-man
however miles as doesn't happen as fast
as Peter and Gwen's
purely because he's still behind them
ability wise miles looks at the
spider-man suit and initially his eyes
aren't level with the mask however he
later returns to this and the scene is
repeated but the characters face is
level with it
this shows that he's grown into the role
and is finally ready to become
spider-man spider-man noir says that the
wind blows wherever he goes and this is
literally shown every time the character
is on screen we also see his face
slightly in another blinkin he'll miss a
moment and he glitches black and white
unlike the others who are in color penny
is the only one who isn't bitten by a
spider and now she doesn't have the same
abilities as everyone else when they're
all on the ceiling hiding from miles his
roommate later in the movie you can
actually see that penny is squeezed
between them rather than being stuck on
the wall itself Miles discovers that his
uncle is the Prowler and the kingpins
villains attack when Aaron grabs Miles
his vision goes from purple to normal
even before the mask comes off showing
that this reveal has completely disarmed
him mentally Aaron is killed and this
kind of mirrors the death of Uncle Ben
who we know was integral to Peters
origin Marlys is initially rejected by
the spider gang but after his father
tells him he will do good no matter what
he embraces his power and takes a leap
of faith
what's up danger it sounded really cool
in my head when I was writing that book
didn't didn't happen when I said it out
loud
I love how is he's plummeting a shot is
flipped so he's actually ascending into
the air rather than falling to the
ground and it's a brilliant seen the
spider gang attacked the supercollider
and there's a couple of cool little
Easter eggs in the scene that I haven't
actually seen pointed out before
spider-man wah throws a car a tombstone
that's similar to the one from the 1930s
showing that this was pulled from his
dimension the colors also changed to
black and white as he returns to his
dimension
Peter tells Miles to hit the green
button to disable the super collider and
a PlayStation controller flies
past with the triangle button
highlighted on a Playstation controller
the triangle is green and this is a nice
little bit of advertising for Sony's
game console the spider gang traveled
back to their worlds and miles takes on
kingpin fiercely shoutouts Baxter rocky
from reddit who noticed that there's a
fractured bridge that miles and kingpin
land on this is a reference to the
Netflix show daredevil which features
similar iconography in the opening
speaking of daredevil at one point you
can also spot a version of kingpins
family in which his son looks exactly
like Matt Murdock hinting at the kingpin
son being daredevil in that universe
there's also an african-american version
of the family which could be a reference
to Michael Clarke Duncan's version of
the character miles finishes the fight
with him by using the hey move that
Aaron taught him and this avenges his
death with the wisdom that he taught
miles also in some ways it allows him to
get revenge on the character - and it's
a really nice use of this motif miles
closes the doorway and we can also see
the food replicator from Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs flying into it an
anvil hits it - which I'm guessing is
from spider pigs universe the movie ends
with Miles and Jefferson repairing their
relationship Miles finishes his paper
grey expectations
Peter goes back to mga and we get a
tease for next time also shout outs
Oscar Isaacs in the post-credits scene I
cannot wait for that next movie greatest
meme of all time totally unrelated
I actually saw they released a Funko pop
set for the original meme and yes
amazing anyway that's all list and
obviously I'd loved hear your thoughts
on the breakdown and if we missed
anything comment below and let us know
and make sure you check out our analysis
of Iron Man 3 which talks about all of
the best Easter eggs in the film it's
one of our greatest videos ever so I
definitely recommend that you give it a
watch after this if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you it and as a
thank you you access to content early
you want to come chat us after the show
either follow us that heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this Monty
can win the Marvel phase 3 part 2 box
set and all you have to do is comment on
a video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of June and the settle be
shipped out
then to ever get surprised so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you